this time
i thought it was the end
where is my son
i couldn't find him
when you're on a mountain bike you're
kind of on the edge
dead or unconscious i don't know now
the worst case scenario was aaron dying
in that cave we cannot afford the wrong
estimation
[Music]
[Music]
this bustling town sits on the pacific
coast
its large harbor and access to the open
ocean makes it the sport fishing capital
of costa rica
and a hot spot for tourists looking for
sun sea and sand
alexis as note presses record on our
waterproof camera to capture some
vacation memories
it was definitely a party atmosphere on
the boat
alexis is on a large catamaran traveling
from eradura to the white sand beaches
of tortuga
a 17-mile journey across the gulf of
nicoya
109 people are on board
including adriana baracal
and her eight-year-old son sean
everybody's you know enjoying the moment
the weather was beautiful it was a
gorgeous day
[Music]
marine electrician aracelio garcia is
traveling with his wife and
five-year-old son
it was a beautiful day
but when we were halfway to tortuga
it all of a sudden changed
it started getting very rough
and the boat would just go up
being in the boating business for 25
years
i said to myself
something's going on
[Applause]
the passengers have no idea
that below them the waves have smashed
through windows in the boat's hall
the sea is flooding in
and the boat begins to list
when they started handing out the life
jackets i became really worried
we might be going swimming
oh my god
[Music]
without the blink of an eye
the boat starts going down into the
water
it happened so fast
oh my god
i thought it was yet
[Applause]
in just 90 seconds
the catamaran is gone
sinking to the sea floor 500 feet below
[Applause]
the passengers find themselves stranded
in open ocean
nine miles from the closest
choreographer
i think she's dead
i think he's dead
[Music]
i think he's dead
[Music]
one man is dead
others are missing
[Applause]
imagine a hundred people
scrambling everywhere with bottles of
liquor and equipment and things
i kept looking for his head and i didn't
i just didn't see it
ah
where's my son
i couldn't find him
there is one glimmer of hope
marine electrician araciello garcia
managed to call his friend and colleague
back at eradura marina right before
going under you say please help me help
me the ball sink i'm here with my family
i can do nothing and the call is end
word of the disaster spreads to other
boats in the marina
i told my mate
just get ready because what we're gonna
find is
it's nothing we did before
help is on its way
but the rescue boats don't know the
exact location of the sunken catamaran
the ocean is so big
[Music]
you feel helpless
i'm sorry
this just makes me
live that moment
of horror
and terror that we went through
adrienne's eight-year-old son sean has
now been missing for eight minutes
as more time passes it becomes a
struggle to stay above the rough waves
with the hot sun beating down
if the passengers don't get help soon
many could drown
or succumb to exposure
i started looking at the sky and said
god i don't want to die like this
you know this is not the way i want to
die
[Music]
[Applause]
nine miles off the costa rican coast
[Applause]
a waterproof camera captures a tourist
boat capsizing with 109 people on board
not all have survived
others are
i missing see my son
hiya
i couldn't find him
by now the survivors have been in the
water for over 10 minutes
praying that help will soon find them
looking around i can see him
where is the boat
you're in the middle of the ocean
nothing around
i started really thinking this is bad
[Music]
15 minutes
after the boat sank
by chance
a passing freighter spots the stranded
passengers
[Music]
the minute that
everybody saw the boat you could tell
that that restored hope in the group
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the freighter stops
500 feet away
our group was oh we should try and swim
towards the freighter
but then that quickly appeared to be
futile because i think when you're in
the middle of the ocean
you don't realize how far away something
is
only a few passengers are strong enough
to swim through the rough waves to the
safety of the freighter
leaving more than 80 behind
20 minutes after the boat sank
exhaustion sets in
i was very drained very extremely tired
[Music]
i had faith that sean's swimming
abilities were
going to save him what i didn't have
faith was mother nature and
how
she has no bias against anyone
without help soon
many could lose their fight against the
rough waves
[Music]
this chip started like
[Music]
the international signal for sos
now the boats from the marina know
exactly where to go we totally bought
our game and going straight to this play
[Applause]
is
[Music]
pablo's is the first fishing boat on the
scene
looking on one side
like 50 or 60 person everybody say help
me help me me friend i have children
[Applause]
i've never been so happy to see probably
in my life
and got the rob jump into the water
and when i go close
and tell the guy okay take this
behind me
and pull 17 or 18 person
when i got on that boat i felt like
god gave me a second chance
the pablo can only fit 20 people
dozens remain in the water
everybody was desperately trying to get
on that boat
seeing them float away was like an
eternity to me i didn't know if i would
ever see sean again and i'm pretty much
left by myself in the in the ocean
wondering if there was any more boats
coming
40 long minutes after the boat sank
the only thing you can see was people
raising hands asking for help
he threw us a rope so that's when you
knew like okay this is the boat that's
taking us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes that's right
[Music]
one
two
three
okay
um
[Music]
you need help
[Music]
captain mimo pulls another 17 victims
out of the water
for those left behind
their only hope is if other fishing
boats reach them
and terrifyingly adriana's
eight-year-old son sean
is still missing
i uh i just didn't know what to do
i didn't know he could survive that what
we had gone through
[Music]
nine miles off the costa rican coast
a catamaran sinks with 109 people on
board
after an hour in rough conditions
help arrives
but nearly half of the shipwrecked
passengers still need rescue
[Music]
and one mother
doesn't know the fate of her
eight-year-old son
my first question to memo is to find out
where sean was
[Music]
they go on to the radio
other people are trying to console me
and then in about five minutes they said
sean was safe
shawn was pulled down with the sinking
boat it's a miracle he survived
i got caught under the sunroof
i was under the water for like a minute
and then it took me five big
breaststrokes to get to the surface
makes me feel like
an angel was watching me
and
now i'm thankful that angel was watching
me because if they weren't i would have
died
[Music]
but not everyone
is so fortunate
three tourists die in the tragedy
i look at my son and i say what a strong
boy he is
because i can't imagine what he went
through
paul does hate
thank god i'm here and i'm telling you
the story
[Music]
this small town is 3 000 feet up in the
sierra nevada mountains
a cliff top playground for experienced
mountain bikers
when you're on a mountain bike and
you're in downeyville you're kind of in
heaven it's like kind of the mecca
a lot of rocky areas and you're kind of
on the edge you've got to be prepared
roger fuji gears up for a day of riding
alongside ericsson alvarez
and adrian merced
his name's adrian but we all call him
dre
ever since i've known him he's been an
extreme guy mine when i turn it on it
might be reports
dre and roger wear cameras to capture
the excitement
all right let's do it
you're in the middle of a mountain just
riding a bike doing what you really love
we talk pretty personal stuff
and dre mentioned his wife jane was was
pregnant
he was super excited
i was thinking i'm gonna enjoy this with
dre cause he's gonna go all out
that's like a death cookie right there
boom
okay this will just take us down
we did the hard part already
you know the hard technical part when
you really had to concentrate on
not worth the uh approaching the end of
their run roger turns off his head cam
i'm not trying to kill my battery going
up this hill
dre's camera
keeps rolling
huh
so
hey
uh
dre has plunged more than 200 feet
straight down the cliff side
slamming his head in the process
he's fallen out of sight of his friends
we're calling his name for like
i say a good eight minutes
calling him calling dre drake where are
you where are you
cuz he's not answering no one answers
dead or unconscious i don't know
[Applause]
in the sierra nevada mountains
mountain biker dre merced has plunged
200 feet
down the side of a cliff
his friends have no idea where he's
fallen
thinking that he might have died was one
of the scariest moments of my life
i can't believe he just told me
he's gonna be a dad and that this is
really happening
[Music]
after a while i finally heard him
there was blood on his forehead
[Music]
you can crack this helmet
and told him don't move
you know we're going to get you some
help
[Music]
by the 911 fire department depending on
the significance of the injury the
survivable rate goes down
especially if they're bleeding
internally or externally
[Applause]
we just basically load up and we head in
the trail
as dre's friends examine his wounds they
turn off his body cam
it's an agonizing wait for help
the fireman's route is a 25-minute trek
across the mountain cliffs
upon arrival is basically oh this is
going to be a bad one
after a medical assessment
roger turns his head cam on
yeah
all right say hi to the cameras right
jason
he's complaining about back injuries
damage to his spine could result in
paralysis
there's a risk dre could never walk or
ride again
my concern is unseen injuries like
internal injuries head injuries
if dre has severe internal injuries
it could lead to organ failure
at any moment dre's condition could turn
from potentially life changing to life
threatening
this individual needs to get into an
ambulance we need to do it now
the helicopter is the fastest most
efficient in this circumstance
you're saving a lot of time
he was under the canopy of the trees and
it would be unsafe to
raise him through the tree branches
their only option is to carry dre 30
feet to a clearing
but moving him comes with enormous risks
you want zero movement in their neck
otherwise they could be
paralyzed
root
is a sheer cliff
oh yeah
give me this bag
covered in loose rock that could give
way under the rescuer's feet
[Music]
i want everybody to find a nice level
spot to make sure your footing is really
good the shale's really really nasty
stuff and we're going to go from one
person to the next i don't want anybody
moving their feet that's where we have
the most chance for them to fall out of
our heads and i know you don't want to
go anymore right
all right
let me know when you guys are ready
okay
one two three
[Music]
let me get down
it's painstaking progress
the slightest little movement could ruin
it forever
[Music]
slow movements are safe for dre's spine
but if he's bleeding internally
every extra second they take
reduces his chances of survival
[Music]
all right
got him okay
[Music]
that's probably good in that flat little
spot just set him gently down to the
ground please
but you can hear the chopper coming in
are you coming downstream now
45 minutes after you first fell
the helicopter hoist stray off the cliff
his future
is now in their hands
we said a prayer and said
spray that
dre's gonna walk away from this and
he'll be riding with us again
you're on record
hey
here i am at uh hospital medina
so you can see my battle scar here so
brazing's on my lower back one of my
biggest fears was
the severity of the injury am i going to
be able to actually take care of my kid
am i going to be able to hold my child
when he's born it's the wifey taking
care of me
six months later after multiple
surgeries on his leg and shoulder
incredibly dre recovers
i was able to hold
you know my son
and
able to
be the kind of father i wanted to be
[Music]
i'm incredibly grateful for
being able to walk out of
such an incident
it's almost like
you're given a second chance
as the sun rises
a panicked call is received by the
slovenian cave search and rescue team
the first information for this mission
was that incept is an injured person
the call is coming from the prima donna
cave system
its only entrance is near the summit of
the 6 000 foot mountain it is hard
accessible it is very cold like 2
degrees celsius and it is very narrow
the victim
20 year old cave explorer aaron paul is
part of a british university caving
expedition
[Music]
a rock has fallen six feet
and struck him in the back
he can't move his legs
suggesting spinal damage and severe
internal injuries
there are 1 000 feet of vertical climbs
and narrow squeezes
between him
and any hope of survival
aaron could not move
the chief concern was that someone
staying
immobile
in a cave as cold as the one in slovenia
is hypothermia
7 a.m
cameras turn on
rescuers prepare to head towards the
cave entrance
before it's too late
in the deep places of prima donna the
simple fact is that help is
really several hours away
the worst case scenario was aaron dying
in that cave
while we were waiting for the rescue to
arrive
deep beneath the surface of a slovenian
mountain british caver aaron paul lies
severely injured and hypothermic
while his friends try to sit tight
this was serious you have to wait it's
almost like an endurance
test a helicopter takes first responders
to the cave's only entrance
the position of
entrance of the cave
is between
top on the bottom of vertical cliff
the helicopter couldn't touch the ground
because there was no flat surface to
land
it takes two hours navigating narrow
caves and sheer cliffs
before finally
the team reaches their patient
thankfully
aaron's still alive
we were shaken but relieved
i felt that he was in the best possible
hands
first we have to do all the first aid
and after that the doctor is in charge
how the patient will be moved
blankets reduced the risk of aaron
succumbing to hypothermia
but the medical assessment reveals
his back injuries
are worse than the rescuers ever
expected
he can move his legs and not feel
his legs
we suspect a spine injury
it is very important that we put the
victim into a stretcher
the backboard stabilizes his spine
reducing risk of further damage
but its size and rigid shape drastically
slows their ascent through the narrow
caves
as time passes
tissues and nerves around aaron's spinal
injury
are deteriorating
left too long without specialized
medical care
this can lead to paralysis
or worse
he
can get some neurological
problems
the worst outcome of spine injuries
is
death
we need to do
fast
but
be careful and safe
after two hours
the team have gone just 100 feet
and worse is up ahead
we had several different locations in
the cave
it was needed to do the widening
to put the victim in a stretcher through
you can work only with a big hammer in
your hands which physically is very
tough
three hours in
the rescuers have traversed less than
200 feet of cave
the slow progress starts to affect the
patient
he has pains and i was
really bored
every time i think about about time
time is life
if we just continue manually with bare
hands and hammers
it would last days
the rescuers are forced to use their
last resort
explosives
the use of explosive in rescue operation
is demanding decision
get this wrong
and the explosion could bury aaron
and his rescuers alive
we are afraid
but
we must focus and
do the best
deep within a slovenian mountain
caver aaron paul puts his life in the
hands of a rescue team there was a fear
that maybe he would lose the the use of
his legs
to get aaron to the urgent medical care
he desperately needs his rescuers are
forced to use explosives to blast their
way through the narrow caves
it was quite dangerous because the rock
was not solid
we cannot afford the wrong estimation
fuzzy mini
[Music]
yeah
the dynamite has worked
first
[Music]
[Music]
nine hours into the rescue
the team still has 750 feet of narrow
passageways to navigate
at five more points they have to blast
their way out
we didn't realize at the beginning how
tough it will be
tempers begin to fray
18 hours into the rescue
they are within 100 feet of the cave's
entrance
it was very late
we were all very tired
one vertical bit and he was out from the
cave
rescue is agonizingly close
but dragging aaron vertically puts more
pressure on his already damaged spine
[Music]
it's a risk they have to take
if we make some mistakes he can be
paralyzed
starving
we have a one person who is monitoring
the stretcher
if
they have to stop he just screams stop
please
19 long hours after the rescuers first
reached their patient
an army helicopter collects aaron from
the precipice
[Music]
we
fulfill our task
he was on a safe way
to the hospital
we cannot do miracles but we really do
the best what we can
at the emergency room
scans reveal fractures to aaron's lower
five vertebrae
incredibly
he's able to fully recover
it's now been almost three years
since i
fractured my spine and i'm caving again
to the same level
something that i love
and enjoy
i owe to those four yard members my life
i'll be forever grateful
when somebody calls us heroes
it doesn't change
anything
once you're in the cave there is no
heroes so
you just do your job
[Music]
you